joining us now for more on all of this
is former U.S ambassador to Russia John
Sullivan he's a CBS News contributor
Ambassador Sullivan thank you very much
for being here the U.S is saying this
shows cracks in Putin's power the
conventional wisdom is certainly that it
was a very bad weekend for him but
explain to us why after all in the end
he did put down this Rebellion
well he put down the Rebellion but at
Great cost he labeled pregosian a
traitor and pragosian was leading a
military column to Moscow and then Putin
struck a deal with him and let him go
free that's extraordinary to call
someone a traitor and then because the
rationale why he had to strike the deal
this is according to the Kremlin
spokesman they needed to avoid Bloodshed
and Chaos what does that say about
Putin's control over the country it
doesn't speak well
yeah what do we know if anything about
what may be in this deal and the role of
Belarus and striking it
well the role of Belarus is particularly
interesting because Belarus and the
president of Belarus president
lukashenka has been completely dependent
on Putin and Russia lukashenka was
re-elected in a in a sham election in
August 2020 massive protests Putin
helped him put those down and kept him
in power now Putin seems to be more
dependent on lukashenka than the other
way around so that's a flip so again
it's it's just there are many examples
of how this these extraordinary events
not only give the appearance of weakness
but actually show real weakness by Putin
Ambassador the world is thinking about
Russia's stockpile of nuclear weapons
this morning the largest in the world
what does this mean for that stockpile
for its future and what should Americans
take away from what's happening in
Russia why does it matter to us well
it's the uh it's really I would think
the preeminent concern of American
officials today who's in control in
Moscow and in particular who's
controlling the largest stockpile of
nuclear weapons in the world that
affects all Americans it affects the
entire world and remember we're talking
about a country that is a permanent
member of the U.N security Council
Russia is supposed to be helping to
guarantee peace in the world instead
it's introduced war and chaos and Putin
controls a massive nuclear Arsenal so
that's a grave concern
all right former U.S ambassador to
Russia John Sullivan thank you very much